okay so what we'll do is we'll go over a
couple of very important things and I
want to make sure today you will learn
the steps even though you're familiar
with it we'll do a review of the steps
and we'll go over a couple of quick
games and do some more tactics okay
lots of tactics we're going to say okay
Discovery's double-checks many different
ideas so again when we start the game so
I want everyone to focus here on the
screen and when you start the game what
is the most important thing you should
try to do first first the what's the
most important thing you need to do okay
great what are squares that we can see
the center what squares is the center so
this square right so let's name this
question we know II 4 d 4 D 5 D 5 these
four squares you know in center of the
word this is the center ok so that's
what you want to do now
let's say we control the center and now
he goes Knight f3 second step after we
do that would be what is the second step
minor pieces okay everybody should know
what are the minor pieces minor pieces
are the Knights and the bishops remember
knights and bishops these are the minor
pieces okay so remember that these are
your minor pieces so we develop your
knight Knights
now this is a very nice game I want to
show you here black plays d6 Bishop g5
Bishop c4 plate and now clearly the
black pieces place this move h6 because
he's worried about the knight jumping
here and attacking on a7 some players
will do that you know they will play
this move just to stop the knight from
coming in so you continue developing and
then he goes Bishop g4 now when he plays
Bishop g4 here now what you're going to
do here huh think about what you're
going to do white to play and find the
combination that will lead to a winning
upon or winning the game via checkmate
okay so you have very nice combination
here that you can try to do here in
order to win it's a famous trap here
that white s if black plays like this
give you a little bit of time to think
here what can you do here because he has
played this each six move which is not a
very good move here okay so you have to
think about it yes well if you go up on
h3 he just goes back it's something
tactical okay it's something tactical
something may perhaps a sacrifice okay
you need to look for okay not just a
regular move some sacrifice idea what
can we sacrifice here because we have
some attack that's a tough one but I
want to give you some time to think yes
excellent very good start
9 take c5 she takes the pawn now let's
see if black takes right away now we can
take the bishop and we're going to end
up with the extra pawn okay
because we want a pawn so that's the
position so that's why when this happens
most of your opponent's are going to be
Wow you're going to take the Queen
they're going to take your queen most of
your opponent's that's what they're
going to do they're going to take your
queen and now who can find the checkmate
in two here's checkmate in two
who can find the mating tune I imagine
that he made them blunder now taking
your queen and you can win this game in
two moves in order to checkmate we need
to start we find a check first sight so
I want you to find the check first here
yes check now can he take it
no can you take a bishop no protected
you can take can he go here no so you
can go here what's the only thing you
can try to do now what's the only thing
he can try to do now
absolutely King g7 only move and now you
should see it now you should see that
now the checkmate here
in order to check when you need to find
a check here right so can you see the
check now can you see the check and what
do you say after that move checkmate
see how that works check let's see can
he go here
why bishop can he go here can he go here
can he go here no right can you block a
check with the night I remember night
check cannot be blocked and the pawn
check cannot be blocked others checks
with the rook bishop and queen they can
be blocked but not the night check and
now after you do this game is over he
cannot do anything it's a miniature okay
it's a very nice miniature you have to
try to remember okay seven moves seven
moves very very nice okay now now we're
going to look at a couple of more games
like this okay so let's see now d4 f5 I
mentioned this before in my lectures
about this opening but let's see if you
can remember maybe you know actually
what is the name of this opening when
black plays this move f5 against d4 and
today I want to also talk about opening
so you know like a lot of these names
and so it will be good for you to know
like what's the name of this opening
Dutch defense when black plays usually
it's a defense right so Dutch defense -
defense very good so this is the Dutch
defense now there is a very nice trap
here okay that I want you to know white
goes Bishop g5 and what a moment it
looks like wait a minute we can just
attack and now black gets really excited
thinking okay I'm going to win the
bishop so it goes g5
you go back he goes f4 and it looks like
what it's really white doing here
he's going to lose his bishop now can
you find a strong move here this is
actually very bad for black can you find
a move here yeah in fact here actually
even in this position can you find a
strong move for white to create his own
threat very nice idea
yes
he's going to take your Bishop if you
move at night
yes clean D - but what if it takes the
bishop what can we do so we don't want
to do that yet right so it's a quiet
move you make this quiet move and you
open a line for your piece and he has a
very strong threat here can you see that
what black is doing is playing a very
dangerous game
he is weakening the position of his king
okay and you can do something to take
advantage of it
yes Pond III you push the pond and it's
going to be like okay he takes your
bishop
and now why is this mob losing ah ha he
goes crenate wife and says checkmate
okay I actually played this position I
got to this point you know I got to this
point then I was really hoping my
opponent would take so I can go check me
but he didn't do that he went 9 f6 so he
stopped that idea okay but I this this
move Bishop g5 it's very interesting
okay Bishop g5 here so you go see it you
play this quiet move but you open up
diagonal okay and you go for the
checkmate and if it takes what do we do
now
we go Queen each wife and say checkmate
okay another little trap okay that you
can use to win a game now now we're
going to look at another famous at the
game okay
so why go see four so this is you
probably most of you play E for first
move right so 9 f 3 play do you know
what to do do you know what to do when
opponent plays this bad move f6 how to
punish this move because it's a really
bad move here anybody know this okay so
let's try to think so we can see what
can we do here this one is practically
losing but you need to know how ok you
need to know how to take advantage of it
okay let's see when you think you have
it raise your hand yes
Bishop c4 it's going to be a good decent
move you're developing but better ok
better what else you can try to the
Bishop c4 is good what else
yes
explore
idea is good idea is good but I know you
want to go Quinn a track check but he
will stop you by playing g6 he will stop
you okay
so that's not something else we need to
do here let's let me give you a little
bit more time to think what else you can
try to do
yes 95 he takes yeah
it's a tactical idea it's a tactical
idea we're going to start with the
sacrifice here okay so we need to find a
sacrifice let's see a sacrifice yes
correct
Knight takes e5 right Knight takes e5
very good so he's going to accept the
sacrifice it's going to take now when he
does that what do you do now when it
takes and accepts your sacrifice when it
takes and accept your sacrifice
now when you sacrifice you have to go
for checks try to find something that
you can do attacking you can just start
developing normally because you just
give up a piece for a pawn you have to
try to do something active okay
in the back five check correct check now
Black has two options here
let's analyze both of these options if
it plays g6 who can tell me why this
move is bad no no it's white to move he
goes here it's white to move why is this
bad what can you do with the Queen not
think about it what can you do with the
Queen check and where we call this in
chess double attack or fork very good
survive a double attack or fork so you
win the rook he comes here that's it we
win the rock - two pounds and a rock so
game is over
white is winning here so he has to go
here now
now what can you do here yes dink-dink
is this the best check you have think is
this the best check that you have okay
yeah well he just say that he just say
that move you have something better you
just say that move you know but you have
something better because he goes Knight
f6 yes correct
Queen takes e5 check now he has only one
squared to go to and that square is f7
now continue when you have an attack
like this you don't slow down you
continue with the initiative here and
try to see if you can try to checkmate
the King very quickly here yes see try
to get more pieces involved you don't
want to just go go in check yeah try to
get more pieces in because with one
Queen we cannot checkmate
we need more pieces in right that's what
we need yes Bishop c4 correct check now
he is trying to go here bishop d5
doesn't do anything bishop take so he's
trying to go here he's trying to escape
so he doesn't get checkmated what you
going to do now can you find the most
effective way to checkmate him in the
back yeah
well you don't want to go back try to
keep the initiative going and try to
find another check try to find another
check good check good check though yeah
yeah you don't go here they'll take you
who can find a good check here to push
this King more to the corners who can
find a good check here
Oh perfect he goes here now
now his king is in really strange
position what should we do - we say
check again and bring another piece into
the game here huh what can we do to
bring another piece not the ones we
already have in the game another one d3
or d4 doesn't matter okay check now he
is going to go g5 to block it
Queen g5 is just bad because of which
move checkmate right bishop is guarding
it so he has to go here now
what do you do now now you have a strong
move you're going to get another piece
now involved into the attack and after
this it's going to be very difficult for
him to do anything if you get one more
piece in here that would be great
think think which piece you want to get
in which piece you can get in yes yeah
Bishop g5 Queen takes so it's protected
yeah in fact it to do it wasn't
protected you can just go clean g5 made
but it's protected yes
yeah but 93 it's not really helping us
is too far away from the king
okay what a stink about it it's an it's
not a very easy move to find but you can
do it think what can you do here to try
to attack him a little bit more
you excellent
h4 now you're getting this look into the
game as well right and now you're
threatening discovery checks so let's
say he go here d6 attacking you
checkmate in two now checkmate in two
let's see who can find it here and next
move I want you to find is a double
check double check who can find a double
check and explain afterwards what is a
double check yes
what g5 pawn takes g5 what is the
context tree five do and what is double
check correct and when that happens what
is the he needs to do here that's the
only thing he can do when right the only
thing you can do it's a double check to
move your king if you cannot move your
king anywhere that's checkmate
so he goes here now and let's see now
checkmate in one
give you a little bit time to think
little bit time to think to find it one
move and the game is over okay go ahead
what about my tics I can take if you go
here you're close but better that is a
checkmate right King cannot go anywhere
and cannot take the Queen because it's
protected by the bishop okay and that's
it you cannot do anything okay very good
very good now we learn couple of
miniatures today okay a couple of
miniatures like you know seven move 11
move now it's time to do some tactics
okay so we're going to be doing many
different tactics okay and we're going
to start off with an idea that is called
decoy sacrifice okay
decoy is when you sacrifice something to
force opponent piece where you want it
to go okay
and also when it's protecting something
you sacrifice and he moves away so let's
start up with this first position here
okay you have so this position looks
very bad for white because this rooks
are very active and he is threatening to
go here and checkmate in one move but
you have a very nice idea and after this
idea you're going to be able to
checkmate in two moves okay
white to play checkmate in to remember
there is a if you check he can escape
here so there is no background check
mate okay King can go here so if you're
planning to just say check that's not a
checkmate he escapes so you need to do
something better you need to sacrifice
something to force opponent piece to a
certain square you want to and that is
called decoy sacrifice okay decoy
sacrifice here so we'll do a couple of
decoys today
okay yes ah that's a nice idea but let's
let me change this it's good for you but
you're not going to be able to checkmate
let's say in two moves yeah you can
capture the Queen here so but our goal
is to checkmate in two moves okay so
let's say the player is a pawn here you
can capture so what do you really do
here to checkmate in two moves that is
your goal your answer should be
checkmate in two okay
and remember he is threatening to come
here and say checkmate he is threatening
to do that okay let's see it's a very
nice move it's a brilliant move first
move it's not a regular move it's a
brilliant idea yes yeah you
you could go 97 but I'm not sure what do
you do after this move no checks and his
threats still remaining okay so in his
stress are still remaining okay so you
got to do something better something
better needed here
first smooth decoy sacrifice you don't
have that many pieces you can sacrifice
here yeah two pieces queen or the rook
queen or a rook it has to be a check -
has to be a check move your moves have
to be checked because otherwise he's
going to check make you on the square on
g2 that it shows you have to see the
whole board okay in order to find this
fun because it's a long-range move okay
just raise your hand only to make any
noise yeah just raise your hand just
hand is good I can see it okay it's a
sacrifice yeah but he escapes see I
mentioned he escapes here and no more
checks no more checks okay well I know
but you you run out of checks but his he
still has this Shack he still has this
Shack and coming here so he still has a
lot of threats better better
let's see now who can find the move here
it's a decoy sacrifice yes
no better night h6 unfortunately I just
take an hour up more material and no
threats what else we can sacrifice with
the check what else any other piece you
can see huge any other piece sacrifice
with the check with the check
okay go ahead correct
Queen FA check sacrificing the Queen
usually Queen sacrifice are very hard to
reject okay because if you reject you
get mated so in this particular example
if you go here now you see the checkmate
do you see the checkmate in one move
correct Knight is protecting it
that is a checkmate perfect so he has to
take now
now what do you do if it takes what do
you do if it takes
back rank checkmate you see how this one
works
not easy one I know not an easy one but
now you see what decoy means sacrificing
a piece to forcing the opponent piece to
a certain square you want it and that is
called decoy decoy sacrifice let's do
this one this was a tough one I know but
I took a long time it's not like you
found it quickly now we're going to do
some more decoys okay the next decoy is
you want to win the Queen okay white to
play and your goal is not to checkmate
okay here your goal is to win his Queen
okay
don't rush I think it's not so simple
yet you have to think a little bit I
want a few minutes thinking before you
raise your hand dig dig
right when I say to it
raise your head okay well you might see
the idea but you have to do something
I'm pretty sure you need to think a
little bit more how about I give you
another one minute to think not too long
one minute think check your answer don't
just look at one good move for you and
assume you're going to win look also
what opponent can try to do okay
it's a decoy idea and you win a tent
with a skewer skewer
yeah yeah just just raise your head yeah
the best if you just raise your head now
we'll be great all right so what's the
first tool here huh
yeah here well you see it take your
queen don't do that okay let's see yeah
but you need a skewer yeah Queen c2 is
just a normal move you're making now
it's something very nice brilliant I
would say again for this one do you see
all the squares your queen can go to all
the squares very nice very very nice in
order to see the combination you have to
see the first move first and see what it
does really tell us why you play this
move
so he has to take the Queen because
queen is pinned so he takes and now look
his Queen was close to the king so by
doing this you move it further away now
and now nice skewer go ahead
clean all the way see that's why I say
look at the long-range moves yeah look
at that see yet check
he has to come up and then you take the
quiz okay
okay so remember that if you would have
played this move right away this
wouldn't be effective this wouldn't be
effective because you would just go here
okay
now he comes here and if you take you
can take back okay now so if you go
through c7 you force him to take and
then you skewer okay what I want to do
is I want to make sure that everyone
here is familiar with tactical ideas
okay so everybody familiar with the fork
yeah and then let me ask you a question
you can fork with how many pieces with
how many pieces you can fork do you know
the answer so let's say you have let me
put all the pieces here let's say you
have rope Queen you have six pieces
right on the board King Queen rook
Knight Bishop and pawn with how many of
these pieces you can fork with what do
you think how many pieces you can fork
with here yes
now just an example no it's just an
example like you can only work with
which piece only with the Queen not with
the night so let's see how with which
pieces you can fork aha so you can fork
with all your pieces the answer is okay
you can fork with all your pieces
remember that now next question is next
question is what about the pin you can
pin with how many pieces can you pin
with all six pieces think carefully
think carefully pin is slightly
different can you fork with all your six
pieces can you pin can you imagine a
pinning with a king
pinning with a pawn
can you pin with the night so you can
pin with how many pieces
how many pieces correct answer you can
pin with three pieces and now we will
see which three pieces who can find a
pin in this position why to play find
the pin you should see it quickly this
is easy yes
yeah I say pin it to win it you pin it
and you win it next one a little bit
more difficult
why to play who can find the pin with
the Queen now you have to look at the
whole board right queen is a major piece
can go from one side all the way to the
other right so you have to start to see
how you can try to find it
let's see now that's a check we're
looking for a pin we're looking for a
pin here yes correct correct where we
call this in chess no in right Bishop is
pin what kind of pin is this we have
even names for the pins right two types
of pins we have this one is called this
one is called what kind of pin absolute
pin that's one if let's say this would
have been a different piece let's say if
this would have been a queen here what
kind of pin is this very good relative
pin so we have pins like that absolute
pin means it's absolutely pin you cannot
move it even if you want to you can
legally move it it's pinned to your King
and we have a relative pin now and let's
see a pin with a rock now who can find a
pin with a rock here should be easy for
you let's see look at the whole board
yes but rookie it is just a check better
you got a pin the piece to win it right
that's a pin to win yes no not him
correct
Rock h3 and tell us please what kind of
pin is this absolute pin because if it's
pin to the king that is called absolute
pin correct now now let's look at the
skewers
how many pieces you can use to skewer
what do you think how many pieces you
can use two skewers let's see which do
Queen because it's the most valuable
piece rook and Bishop right so we can
use three pieces to skewer okay like in
this position who can find the skewer
skewer with the Queen penis when you pin
the piece skewer is when you attack and
then he has to move away you take it
okay now in this position which will be
the skewer correct this is a skewer okay
you go check because if it steps up we
pick up the piece skewer okay now
another skewer block is thinking okay I
have extra Queen here maybe I can try to
win this game but then suddenly comes a
surprise a big surprise here in a
forward skewer let's see if you can find
that surprise skewer here who can find a
surprise skewer and this way you can see
with which pieces you can use to do pins
force and skewers
correct look to h3 all the way here and
now check and what we call this not
skewer okay
skewer because you check the kink he
moves away
that's the skewer okay pin is when you
pin a piece to a king or queen or
something else but this is you attack
right away okay and now we come to the
bishop why to play can you find the
skewer with the bishop now yes
skewer with the bishop who can find a
bishop skewer here okay so you remember
right you can do that it's like a pin
you can skewer with the same pieces like
the pin yes correct correct yeah look at
that what we call that skewer
remember that pins folks skewers these
are very important to remember because
you would win light now a lot of kids by
just knowing those which pieces can
skewer which pieces can pin and always
look for these tactical ideas double
attack fork you know skewer so now you
go check he has to move away you take
the piece game is over
okay so hallways have to look for this
ideas okay so let's start up from the
beginning so everybody know today's
lesson you can fork with how many pieces
what is the answer we can fork with how
many pieces six all of your pieces okay
how many pieces you can pin with three
which are piece at a bishop now four
skewer its same thing Bishop rook and a
queen and now the last position for
today will be how to fork with the king
hey we talked about forking with a king
black just played Knight f6 24 saying
check thinking it's a good movie you
checked but it's a bad move now and who
can find a fork here attacking two
pieces at the same time correct King D 3
attacking the bishop and a knight that
is a fork okay remember that for example
if he also had a pawn here you would
have done the same thing you would have
come up and say fork okay because now we
cannot move this ideas okay okay very
good it's very important to remember
this ideas okay so the pins and folks
and skewers and also we talked about
decoy today when you sacrifice something
it removes the decoy you sacrifice
something to force upon it to a certain
square you want it to go